few saw it coming to this russia
launching a war on its democratic
neighbor vladimir putin told russian
business leaders he had no option
they've created such security risks we
could not react differently he said
vladimir putin a one-time kgb operative
has long feared the west's threat to
russia's security for 20 years he has
rebuilt or forced compliant
relationships on russia's borders
but ukraine would not comply in 2014
mass protests and unrest ousted the
kremlin-friendly ukrainian leader
putin and russia almost immediately took
over crimea and backed rebel unrest
elsewhere but the risk remained of
ukraine slipping from russia's historic
influence and control that reassertion
of the russian sphere of influence
ukraine is the grand prize
everybody else is like small potatoes
ukraine is strategically crucial to
russia's own sense of security it fears
a potential gateway for nato into the
russian heartland if ukraine becomes a
nato member is that
russia's
military capabilities capacity and its
own security would be at risk
but if russia's military campaign is
successful it could destabilize the west
the target is the stability in europe
and the whole of the international peace
order putin has appealed to russian
patriotism for support
but even at home there are russians who
oppose the invasion risking arrest for
speaking out
the usually pragmatic russian leader has
now played his cards revealing just how
large are his fears and his ambitions
eric sorensen global news toronto